Est-ce qu'il est vraiment
facile d'apprendre une langue avec chat GPT ?
le plus grand paradoxe pour l'apprentissage des langues
c'est qu'avec l'intelligence artificielle
il n'a jamais été aussi inutile d'apprendre une langue
et en même temps ça n'a jamais été aussi facile
et ce paradoxe
il est valable pour tout ce qui touche
à la connaissance
nous n'avons jamais eu accès à autant de connaissance
et de savoir gratuitement
et pourtant ça nous a jamais été aussi inutile
à quoi bon apprendre l'histoire de France
alors que Chat GPT peut vous faire un résumé complet
en quelques secondes
pourquoi apprendre une langue
alors que tout est de plus en plus traduit
automatiquement
sur YouTube par exemple
vous avez de plus en plus de vidéos
directement
traduites et doublées dans n'importe quelle langue
vous pouvez même regarder Mister Beast en français
j'ai recréé chaque décor de Squid Game
dans la vraie vie
et celui qui
parmi ces 456 personnes
survit le plus longtemps
gagnera 456 000 dollars
idem si vous êtes au Japon
en Chine ou dans n'importe quel pays qui utilise
un autre alphabet que le vôtre
il vous suffit de sortir
Google traduction et d'utiliser l'appareil photo
par magie
tout est traduit et tout est directement accessible
sans effort
à cette question
pourquoi apprendre une langue
ma réponse est plutôt simple
c'est juste que c'est intéressant
c'est amusant
c'est stimulant
ça fait travailler notre mémoire
notre cerveau
notre façon de réfléchir
et ça nous ouvre des portes sur d'autres cultures
tout ça c'est assez évident
ce que je veux dire c'est que toutes ces technologies
visent plutôt à répondre à une contrainte
en France par exemple
parler anglais
c'est une compétence qui peut être valorisée
dans le cadre du travail
car ça permet de travailler avec des personnes
de n'importe quel pays
et je pense que ça va être de moins en moins valorisé
jusqu'à devenir inutile
mais si on compare avec d'autres disciplines
on peut facilement comprendre
pourquoi l'apprentissage des langues
ne va pas disparaître
personnellement j'ai peur du vide
donc quand je vois des gens faire de l'escalade
j'ai juste envie de leur dire
qu'est-ce que tu fous ??
pourquoi t'es accroché au bout d'une corde
à 30m de haut ??
on a inventé les hélicoptères
les ascenseurs
mais non certaines personnes
s'obstinent à vouloir monter des falaises
parfois même sans sécurité
et ça c'est applicable à beaucoup de discipline
tous les gens qui courent des marathons
il faudrait peut-être leur dire qu'on a inventé
la voiture
bref ce que je veux dire
c'est que malgré les évolutions technologiques
ça vaudra toujours le coup d'apprendre une langue
on apprend pas une langue pour répondre à une contrainte
on apprend une langue parce que c'est intéressant
la question maintenant c'est donc de savoir
comment utiliser cette technologie
pour faciliter son apprentissage
comment utiliser chat GPT
pour apprendre plus facilement
et je vais donc vous présenter
ce que je fais pour mon apprentissage du japonais
mais et j'insiste sur ce mais
chat GPT ne va pas vous rendre bilingue
si vous voulez devenir bilingue
il faut construire une habitude
c'est-à-dire passer 15
30 minutes voir 1h par jour
à apprendre le français
ou n'importe quelle autre langue
Chat GPT est un outil
et vous devez-vous en servir
vous ne devez pas attendre
qu'il fasse tout à votre place
bon on peut commencer
la première étape c'est de faire connaissance
on va appeler ça le
ce que je veux dire
c'est que la force de Chat GPT
c'est qu'il va s'adapter à vos besoins
il va prendre en compte
votre niveau et vos objectifs
et ensuite vous pourrez lui demander
tout ce que vous voulez
et il s'y adaptera
au fur et à mesure que vous échangez avec lui
dans la langue que vous apprenez
il va identifier vos faiblesses et il pourra ensuite
vous aider à les améliorer
pour ça
vous pouvez commencer par quelque chose comme
je suis A2 en français
afin de m'améliorer
est-ce qu'on peut parler en français
et tu me corriges mes erreurs si besoin
ensuite il faut construire un historique
il faut parler avec lui
et d'ailleurs il vous propose même des thèmes
tout ce que vous allez écrire
et toutes les fautes que vous allez faire vont être
utiles parce qu'il va s'en rappeler
et ça permettra d'identifier vos faiblesses
d'où le nom weaknesses targeting
la deuxième étape c'est construire un plan
alors je ne suis pas fan de cette méthode
mais je vous la montre quand-même
c'est assez simple
en gros
je suis niveau A2 et je veux être B2 dans un an
en travaillant 15 minutes par jour
fais-moi un plan détaillé
et il va vous donner un plan
plus ou moins détaillé selon ce que vous demandez
c'est pratique
mais attention
il faut prendre ça comme une recommandation
on est tous différents par rapport à l'apprentissage
et certaines choses sont plus efficaces que d'autres
selon notre profil
donc il ne faut surtout pas
appliquer bêtement ce que vous dit chat GPT
prenez toujours du recul
et voyez ses réponses plus comme un conseil
si je prends sa réponse
il va par exemple me dire de faire de la compréhension
orale pendant 3 mois
puis de la lecture pendant 3 mois
c'est un peu déséquilibré
et ça ne prend pas vraiment en compte
la manière dont vous aimez travailler
donc soyez vigilant
demandez-lui de l'aide pour construire un plan
mais n'hésitez pas à le modifier à votre manière
j'insiste à nouveau là-dessus
mais ce qui va faire votre réussite
ce n'est pas les objectifs que vous fixez
ce sont les habitudes que vous vous créez
la troisième étape
c'est de pratiquer de la grammaire et du vocabulaire
un peu tous les jours
je fais ça personnellement pour le japonais
et en gros
je lui ai demandé de m'envoyer tous les jours
une règle de grammaire
et un mot de vocabulaire
correspondant au niveau que je vise
pour le japonais c'est le JLPT N2
avec bien sûr des phrases d'exemple
ne demandez
surtout pas des listes de vocabulaire à chat GPT
c'est vraiment pas efficace
apprenez toujours votre vocabulaire dans des phrases
et là c'est donc quelque chose que vous pouvez intégrer
directement dans votre apprentissage
personnellement
je transforme
ce qu'il me donne en flashcard avec l'outil Migaku
et donc après
je revois régulièrement les points de grammaire
qu'il m'a donné
mais vous pouvez très bien faire la même chose avec
Anki
la quatrième étape c'est le content adaptation
dans un autre podcast je parlais du contenu idéal
qui est en gros un contenu adapté à ce que vous aimez
et à votre niveau
dans la langue
c'est-à-dire quelque chose de juste
un peu plus difficile
que votre niveau
pour vous permettre de pouvoir lire quelque chose
d'intéressant
sans que ce soit trop difficile
et ça chat GPT est très bon pour ça
en plus
vous ajoutez la fréquence d'utilisation des mots
et c'est magique
en gros
les langues suivent en quelque sorte une loi de pareto
c'est-à-dire que 80% de ce qui est dit ou écrit
utilise environ 20% des mots existants
c'est très approximatif
mais du coup l'idée
c'est de se concentrer sur les mots les plus utilisés
les mots les plus fréquents
et donc on peut demander
créer moi un texte de 1000 mots
sur l'histoire de l'équipe de France de football
adapté à mon niveau
avec les 2000 mots les plus fréquents en français
c'est magique
vous avez du contenu à volonté dans un niveau adapté
vous pouvez ensuite créer des cartes Anki
et je crois d'ailleurs
qu'il y a des manières de l'automatiser
directement avec chat GPT
la dernière étape
c'est la conversation
et là ça devient un peu flippant
en gros vous pouvez parler avec Chat GPT
directement dans la langue de votre choix
et il peut vous corriger ou vous faire pratiquer
c'est très pratique pour pratiquer la conversation
n'importe quand sur n'importe quel sujet
bon par contre la voix est un peu robotique
et je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais Chat GPT a un accent américain en français
et j'ai l'impression en japonais également
à la fin de la discussion
il vous donne même une retranscription
et vous avez aussi la possibilité de réécouter
tous les messages
donc c'est très pratique
bonjour j'aimerais apprendre à parler français
bonjour
avec plaisir je peux t'aider à pratiquer le français
dis-moi ce que tu aimerais apprendre
ou si tu as des questions particulières
et on va faire ça ensemble
je veux pratiquer la conversation
donc je veux discuter autour d'un thème
et si besoin tu corriges mes erreurs
avec grand plaisir
on peut choisir un thème qui t'intéresse
par exemple les voyages
la cuisine
ou même le quotidien et je te corrigerai si besoin
pas de souci alors quel thème te ferait plaisir
euh je vais parler de mon quotidien
super idée alors raconte-moi un peu comment
se passe une journée typique pour toi
et je t'écouterai avec attention
ça sonne un peu américain
super idée
le matin je me lève
à 6h et je bois la café
ok parfait c'est très clair
juste une petite correction on dit je bois du café
sinon c'est très bien continue
je mange des tartines avec de la beurre
très bien c'est parfait continue comme ça
si tu veux-tu peux
poursuivre en décrivant ce que tu fais ensuite
et je t'écouterai avec plaisir
merci
euh j'aime apprendre la français tous les jours
c'est super et c'est très bien dit
on dira juste
j'aime apprendre le français tous les jours
bon par contre
parfois j'ai l'impression qu'il
passe à côté de certaines erreurs
voilà donc comment
chat GPT peut vous aider
à apprendre plus rapidement une langue
je le redis une dernière fois
mais c'est un outil qui vous aide à apprendre
il ne va pas apprendre à votre place
alors construisez une habitude
faites un peu tous les jours
et quelle que soit votre méthode
vous allez progresser